Ja, herzlich willkommen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcast-UFO. Das war schneller vorbei, als ich dachte. Das war He said. Herzlich willkommen. Das war Clemens. Das war He said. Das war He said. Und We said. Und We said. Ja. Das war Clemens. Vielen Dank an Clemens für dieses fantastische Intro. Es hat uns in die richtige Laune gebracht für diese Folge Podcast UFO, denn fantastische Folge heute, Stefan Tietze ist da und Florian Will ist da, wir beide mal wieder zusammen in einer Folge Podcast UFO. Wir sind entspannt, die Tour ist vorbei, der Sommer steht uns kurz vor. Du hast gerade letzte Folge in dem Magazin aufgezeichnet, das heisst, wir sind durch eigentlich. Wir sind im Urlaubsmodus, aber ich habe ja dieses Interview mit dir gehört, du bist ja momentan in aller Munde, du bist ja gar nicht so der Urlaubsmensch, du kannst ja gar nicht so gut abschalten, also du musst ja immer was machen. Ja, sagt man in diesem Interview, sagt man das dann immer so, um halt die Schlagzeilen, man denkt ja die Schlagzeile schon mit, ich denke ja die Bildschlagzeile, Tietze kann nicht abschalten, ja schon mit quasi Nee, das stimmt wirklich. Aber ich glaube, zwei Wochen Urlaub, da kann ich schon abschalten. Also du machst auch Tietze frei, oder was? Ich mache schön Tietze frei. Und dann, es klingt ein bisschen versaut, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich würde wirklich, zwei Wochen Urlaub finde ich nicht so problematisch. Wir fliegen ja auch eine Woche zusammen weg. Und so, ich glaube, das ist dann auch, da kann ich nur abschalten. Wenn es dann so in die sechs Wochen Urlaubphase geht,
ich weiß nicht, ob es dir auch so geht, aber nach drei Wochen
denke ich mir, was macht ein Menschen denn dann
jetzt? Und dann fange ich an, wieder Dinge zu machen.
Ja, das stimmt. Der Mensch braucht Dinge,
die er machen kann. Ja, das ist auch
so ein Urinstinkt. Man braucht einfach Dinge, die man
machen kann. Das ist immer so, wenn
die Mondmission zurückkommt, war auf dem Mond und dann
fragt der Reporter so, warum waren sie auf dem Mond?
Und der Astronaut so ... Sonst setze ich halt nur zu Hause rum. Meine Frau und ich sitzen uns die ganze Zeit auf Füße. Ja, aber das hat mehrere Milliarden Dollar gekostet, vier Schimpansen sind gestorben, drei ihrer Kollegen sind gestorben. Wenn man raus muss, muss man raus. Das sind auch die besten Sprichworte. Das sind immer Dinge, die man doppelt sagt. Das Küt das Küt? Ja. Mal ja Kölner, ne? Que sera, sera. Ich weiß nicht genau, was es heißt, aber es sind auch zweimal das gleiche Wort. Das gleiche, was küt das küt. Was kommt das kommen, wer schreibt, der bleibt. Gut, da macht es doch noch Sinn. Okay, vielen Dank, Mr. Armstrong. Ja, klar, gern. Ciao, oder wie wir sagen, bye bye. Ist man eigentlich durch nach der ersten Raummission oder sagt man dann mal normal, oder? fuck it, komm, ich stell mich nochmal hinten an ja, ich weiß nicht genau, hast du den Film erst First Man geguckt? nee, da geht er um ihn und wie seine Frau mit der Angst leben musste auch ihren Mann wahrscheinlich zu verlier verlieren. Ja. Was natürlich auch sein Grauenvolles.
Warum denn?
Das ist doch gefährlich.
Das ist doch arschgefährlich, da hochzufliegen.
So wurde es im Film formuliert, in der Exposition.
Nee, das war das Poster.
First Man, das ist doch arschgefährlich, oder nicht?
Die Traumfahrt ist richtig arschgefährlich, also krachowgefährlich.
Was glaubst du, wenn die Cavemen damals saßen um Feuer herum und dem Dorf ging es zum ersten Mal so richtig gut? Es wurde genug gejagt und so. Ich glaube, die konnten auch nicht entspannen. Hat sich da mal jemand aufs faule, was ich sage mal, auf die faule Haut gesetzt? Faule Socke? Auf die faule Haut, nee. Aufs Ohr hauen. Aufs Ohr gehauen? Nee. Auf die faule Haut. Ich weiss es nicht genau, aber ich glaube, ich verstehe schon, was du meinst.
Aber glaubst du denn, dass er sich jemandem hingesetzt hat oder gab es dann schnell so ein Jo-papapap.
Ja, ich glaube gerade vor allem, wenn du halt Mammuts jagst, du jagst einen Mammut und weißt du, wir haben jetzt die nächsten sieben Monate Fleisch.
So, und dann ist erstmal, dann geht auch die Urlaubsplanung los. Genau, dann ... Wollen wir ins All? Einer muss hier bleiben, oder? Einer denkt sich eine Religion aus. So, gut. Das macht ... Paulus ... Religion ... macht die Religion. So, ich würde hier einfach mal ... Ich hab ... Sammeln. Ich hab Bock, Dinge zu sammeln. Ey, sammeln mal. Mir ist Folgendes aufgefallen.
Ich hab diese beiden Holzstöcke gegeneinander geschlagen und dachte mir, ist doch ganz geil. Aber passiert ja nichts. Ja, aber vielleicht kann man da noch ein bisschen mehr rausholen. Oh, Idee. Versteht ihr? T-t-t-t-t. Neeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee E
-Vie
E-Vo Ist nicht jedes Bike mobile? Mobike. Mobike? Ach, Motorbike! Nee, es heisstike, die App heißt Mobike. Die steht überall rum wie Car to go, nur für Bikes. Car to bike, bike to go. Dann ist er rumgefahren und dann haben die ja so ein Dynamo vorne. Dynamo, ich weiß nicht genau, wo da die Betonung ist. Aber anscheinend hat jedes Mobike das Problem, dass der Strom nicht komplett in die Lampe fließt, sondern vor allem in den Körper. Und dann war es immer so, dass ich, immer wenn ich ihn angefasst habe oder man sich berührt hat irgendwie, haben wir beide einen enormen Stromschlag bekommen. Aber das war kein Stromschlag, wie man den so kennt, aus Spaß, von Rolltreppen oder so, oder wenn man mal über den Teppich geht, mit Rutschesocken. Nee, es war so ein richtig schöner Rutsch, also wo auch Leute dann zurückgeschreckt sind, beide so ein
Ah! Also wirklich, das war
ganz lustig der
Nachmittag, weil man die ganze Zeit
ihn anfassen konnte und es so ein
gab, so ein Funkenflug auch.
Ich finde, die sollten damit werben einfach für Mowbike.
Fun Fun auf dem Bike. Einfach kommst relativ schnell
voran, nicht so schnell mit dem Auto, aber du kommst relativ schnell
voran, ist ein bisschen anstrengend. Die mit den Funken.
Ja, genau. Die mit dem Strom. Au, fuck, Alter, was war das denn? Die mit dem Stromspaß. Das ist die ganze Werbung. Au, Alter! Mobike, ah! Ja, aber das war wirklich ganz großer Spaß. Spaß mit Strom. Du kannst mir doch jetzt nicht allen Ernstes erklären, dass du verstehst, was da passiert, oder? Im Mobike? Nee, mit dem Strom. Ach so. Nee, ich weiß nicht genau. Weiss man auch nicht. Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine chinesische Firma, Mobike. Okay, so viel hast du verstanden. Ja, so viel habe ich verstanden. Und ich habe auch verstanden, dass die damit wohl den Verkehrsfluss in Europa ausspionieren wollen. Gut, das ist von mir jetzt rein interpretiert. Die wollen untersuchen, wie Verkehrsflüsse funktionieren, wie Menschenmassen sich bewegen und haben deswegen ganz viele Fahrräder aufgestellt und untersuchen jetzt uns versuchskaninend den Europäer. Ach, die haben dann so GPS-Tracker und dann kann man genauso. Genau, guckt man, wo man die abstellt und so, wie man von A nach B fährt, um, das ist in meiner Theorie, langsam aber sicher die Weltherrschaft zu übernehmen. Ich verstehe eigentlich nicht, also also warum sich sowas wie Bierbike nicht durchsetzt als Verkehrsmittel, also so ein Fahrrad, wo mehrere Leute drauf fahren, und dann kannst du immer, wenn du da bist, kannst du abspringen und der Rest fährt weiter, wie so ein Bus, nur dass du halt jetzt irgendwie keine Ziele brennen musst. Leute wollen an unterschiedliche Ziele, das ist das größte Problem. Ja, dann baust du auf Schienen. Zug nennt man das. Ja, aber die Fahrgäste müssen es selber antreiben. Und dann, oh, da kommt er und dann musst du halt schnell nebenherlaufen, aufspringen und dann trittst du mit und dann am Ende steigst du aus, da wo du aussteigen willst. Dann hast du auch nicht mit das Problem mit Haltestellen, sondern jeder kann da aussteigen, wo man will. Genial. Aber wenn du auf Schienen bist, dann kannst du nicht aussteigen, wo du willst. Klar, springst einfach ab. Okay, trotzdem auch noch eine Schiene gewonnen.
Finde ich gar nicht so schlecht.
Wie so eine Dreisine, nur halt mit mehr Leuten, die dann selber. Ich glaube, Zug ist die logische Konsequenz dieser Kette, weil wir betreiben die ja auch mit unserem Geld quasi. Also, selbst.
Ja, vor allem immer jetzt, dass die, ich finde es ja so gut, die Bahn ist ja einerseits eine sehr subtile Firma, weil alle so Klimawandel, Rezo, alles klar und die Bahn würde immer gerne sagen, hallo, wir sind auch, brauchst du kein Benzin? Aber es ist halt ein bisschen unsympathisch, wenn du immer in jeder Diskussion so... Hallo, hallo. Hi, ich wollte nur mal hi sagen, die Bahn.
Genau, einmal die Bahn, nur... Bahn hinten, hi! Wie können wir das schaffen? Wir sind nur hier, wir wollen gar nicht... Wir können ja nicht die Autos abschaffen, so. Und dann mit dem ganzen Benzin, das graben wir aus. und verbrennt ganz gut und dann verbrennen wir es. Aber was ist die Alternative? Was ist die Alternative? Boom, boom, Bahn, hi, hey, ganz kurz, hi. Ach, die Bahn! Ich bin ein unangenehmer Gesprächspartner, der auf der Party sich in jeden Freundeskreis so reindrehen will. Und deswegen haben sie jetzt ganz subtil auch ihre ICEs grün gemacht, so als ein kleines Hallo. Wir sind es nur Hi, ä, äh, hallo, wir könnten was machen. Ja, und da ist eine große winkende Hand auch auf die ICE draufgestellt. Ja, ja. Ich war noch nicht in Frankfurt, in einem Kopfbahnhof nennt man das jetzt, glaube ich, ne? Mhm. Wo die reinfahren, und da kam so ein Typ und hat dann mit so einem grossen Wischer die ganzen toten Tiere vorne weggekratzt von der Bahn, das war schon interessant. Es sind meistens so Mücken, aber es hinterlässt so eine braune Schmiererei. Und es ist schon ein bisschen gruselig, dass da so ein Typ mit so einem riesen Scheibenwischer ankommt und dann einfach tote Tiere davon abkratzt. Warum hat man das nie bei Deutschlands schönsten Bahnstrecken? Warum hat man da nicht nach 20 Minuten ein komplett stockschwarzes Bild, weil dann irgendwie so ein Reh und so ein Krokodil und einfach alles weg. Und da geht mir auch der Realismusanspruch des Bahnsimulators so ein bisschen ab, weil da wird es ja auch einfach Sinn machen, dass in einer halben Stunde einfach ein Reh oder der ältere Herr aus dem dritten Stock plötzlich ausrutscht. Oder einfach gesprungen ist. Oder Rico aus der 7D, dem von damals einfach gesagt hat, nee, ich beende mein Leben jetzt. Keine Selbstmörder. Wohingegen im Fliegensimulator ganz grosses Thema Züge, ganz, ganz grosses Thema Züge. Du hast nur einen Tag zu leben. Nicht das grösste Thema. Eines der grössten Themen, Sehen und Züge und du fliegst rum und darfst nicht in den Zug fahren. Ja. Fliegen. Ist aber auch
kompliziert zu spielen, weil du hast sehr viele
Züge halt 80 Millionen Mal,
wegen dieser kleinen, weirden Auflösung
deines Kopfes. Und du lebst halt
48 Stunden, es fühlt sich aber an wie drei Jahre,
weil du nimmst ja alles langsamer wahr.
Ja, laupt den aus. Ich habe lange
den Mörder gezockt und danach ist man ein bisschen ausgelaugt.
Das stimmt, ja. Ganz kurz,
es könnten theoretisch eine Fliege eine andere Fliege stechen? Wenn die gar nichts anderes findet? Stechen die überhaupt? Ja, Mücken halt, mein Gott. Entschuldigung. Ja, okay, du hast jetzt die Biologen-Massakras angeschaut. Ja, okay, cool. Ja, ich sehe ein T-Shirt, Stefan. Ja, weil Fliegen stechen die. Okay, Mücken. Können die andere Mücken stechen zur Not? Das ist dann so, Entschuldigung, entschuldigen Sie bitte. Das ist ein Diebstahl, das ist mein Blut. Ja, wenn eine Mücke gerade Menschen gestochen hat, kommt der andere und und saugt das alles raus. Hm, was denn? Ob das bei dir oder bei dem Menschen ist das auch. Du kannst aber den Menschen jetzt wieder stechen. Dann stehst du auch direkt bei den Menschen. Ja, ich glaube, es fühlt zu einer unangenehmen Situation. Da kommt dann so eine Polizei. Vielleicht sind Wespen die Moskitopolizei. Das kann gut sein. Die dann hinfliegen und sagt, so auseinander erst mal. Jetzt hätte ich gehen mal von beiden, dass wir die Ausweise. Also, nur weil ich mit meinem Stachel in seinem Bauch hier aufgegriffen wurde, heißt das nicht, dass ich Blut stehlen wollte. So, erst mal den Ausweis, bitte. Ich wollte mal reinnicken. Erst mal den Ausweis. Ist ein altes Bild. Das hat man damals so getragen. Das war 20 Minuten das Foto, okay? Sieht nicht aus wie sie. Wie gesagt, vor 20 Minuten. Wir haben ja eigentlich vor ein paar Minuten noch die neuen Ausweise eingeführt. Das ist ein alter Ausweis. Ich lebe noch zwei, zweieinhalb Minuten lebe ich noch. Und da müssen Sie
jetzt kommen und hier so einen großen Ramazammer machen. Ich will noch einmal süsses, süsses, das war ein Vaterjunge. So jemanden wie Sie habe ich noch nie erlebt. Und wissen Sie, wenn ich diesen Job schon mache? Seit gut und gerne 30 Minuten mache ich diesen Job schon. Ja, okay, ich respektiere Sie ja auch. Das ist ja auch wirklich erstaunlich, was Sie geschafft haben in dieser langen Zeit. Oh, oh, oh, oh, schnell, helft die Miner!
und schon die nächste Serie.
So, Moskitos!
Ich fand, in dem Film B-Movie war auch wesentlich mehr drin, als der Film dann rausgemacht hat.
Dass diese ganze Honigthematik natürlich aufgegriffen wurde, aber man auch mal so fragt so, ja, was zur fucking Hölle ist Honig eigentlich? Also ist es deren Wasser oder ist es deren Beefy, wie so ein Beefy to go oder was? Oder ist es, was machen die? Also wie sieht eine Biene Honig? Speichel. Ja, wir müssen irgendwie jetzt hier so achteckige Waben bauen, um den ganzen Speichel zu sammeln hier. Allein was der, guck dir den Depp mal an da, was der da rumspeichelt. Aber ich finde es fantastisch, dass die halt so eine spezifische Form für ihre Waben haben. Da gibt es eine Sechseckechsecke, oder? Ja, ich glaube auch. Und die müssen ja... Fünf. Wie viel Finger hat eine Biene? Kann die so weit überhaupt zählen? Bienenwabe. Jetzt fängt er an zu googeln, der Stefan. Aber mit einer Hand. Er ist jetzt der Intellektuelle. Ah ja, ich sehe es. Sechsecke. Sechsecke. Nee, weil dann ist der Raum halt optimal ausgenutzt. Bei Quadraten wäre es noch ähnlich gut ausgenutzt, aber ich glaube, das wären dann alle Formen. Weil sonst verplemperst du halt Platz. Ja, was ist mit Yin-Yang, dass die so ineinander greifen? Ich glaube, rund funktioniert nicht, weil instabil. Ich glaube, diese Ecke sind schon besser, diese Barben. Aber gab es dann im Prozess der Evolution auch Bienenstöcke, die halt dann irgendwie so einen Stern hatten oder so eine Raute, die einfach ausgestorben sind? Es sah halt schöner aus, aber man hat leider nicht überlebt, ja. Und die waren einfach am effektivsten. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass es das gab. Die haben den Platz nicht optimal ausgenutzt, weil die sich überlegt haben, Hakenkreuze zu machen. Und das kam nicht gut an. Nee, ich glaube schon. Und das ist natürlich am besten jetzt für alle. Deswegen, ich frage mich nur, warum bei Menschen zum Beispiel sich Häuser nicht so durchgesetzt haben, um gut Platz zu sparen und viele Häuser aufzubauen in einem kleinen Radius zum zum Beispiel den Platz optimal, die Thematik gut aussieht.
Ja, aber Bienen leben in der Monarchie, wo einfach die Königin sagt so ...
So wird's gemacht.
Waben bitte und alle so.
Wir machen die Sternformen und jetzt raus hier!
Oh!
Ich würd so gerne eine Partei machen für die Kreise, das geht aber nicht.
Nö!
Och, komm schon, ey!
Nee, ja, ja, ich geh, ich geh schon, Alter.
Nimm mich nicht, Alter.
Ja, das war nicht du, den meinte ich.
Du, vor allem auch, dass sie nur eine Königin haben und so, die offensichtlich auch anders aussieht.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht, warum die Menschen da auf die Monarchie reingefallen sind.
Der sieht doch genauso aus, meinst du? Die Königin sieht genauso aus wie andere Menschen.
Wohingegen bei Bienen, da sehen die ja offensichtlich anders aus. Offensichtlich. Die bessere Form. Wobei ich glaube auch, das hat schon auch einen Grund, warum die eine Moarchie haben, weil das ja auch der Bienen nennt man ja auch der Bienen ist ja die Schwarmintelligenz und der ganze Schwarm funktioniert ja als eine Einheit, ist ja eher als ein Organismus zu verstehen. Also wenn du mal eine Biene dich nervst und die mal so wegschnippst oder kaputt machst, du machst ja den Bienenschwarm an sich, tust du ja da keinen Abbruch. Ja. Sollte man trotzdem nie machen. So ein bisschen wie wenn man jemandem ein Haar ausreißt. Ja genau. Ja, komm. Passt. Ja, ist egal. Hast du einen B-Movie gesehen von James Seinfeld?
Nee, also nur halt in diesen Meme-Versionen irgendwie,
immer wenn jemand B sagt, dann wird es doppelt so schnell und so. Ich habe vorhin einen Film, drei Jahre lang,
und am Ende kennen alle nur die Memes davon.
Aber vielleicht ist es auch egal.
Naja, besser als in der komplette Vergessenheit zu verschwinden eigentlich.
Ich habe es überlegt, bei der Serie auch Memes rauszumachen,
selber rauszubringen.
Aber dann dachte ich, das finde ich ein bisschen blöd.
Ich finde die Memes von Aaron Sorkin, also nicht das jetzt, aber wenn Aaron Sorkin jetzt Memes von Social Network rausbringt, würde ich jetzt auch nicht geil finden. Ist schon nicht so cool, ja, stimmt schon. Genau wie Netflix hat sehr tolle Wallpaper rausgebracht, wo ich überlegt habe, mir davon einen zu machen, aber das Ding ist auch uncool von der eigenen Serie. Ist schon komisch.
Was ist, wenn man dich im ICR antrifft und du schaust gerade deine eigene Serie? Ja.
Ja, du weißt ja, wie es ausgeht.
Ja, ein bisschen komisch alles.
Und währenddessen guckst du dich immer so um und
deutest so mit dem Finger auf. Hey, Leute!
Im eigenen Merge auch und so,
verkleidet als der Main-Character. Hallo.
Weil man als Halloween jetzt als,
mich kann ich ja auch nicht als Charakter aus der Serie gehen. Ja, Man kann eigentlich nicht Fan seiner eigenen Serie sein. Es ist eigentlich schrecklich, wenn du selber, wenn du einfach sagst, auch mal distanziert, die ist einfach richtig geil. Aber kann jetzt nicht im Fanclub auftauchen und sagen, hey Leute, was war eure Lieblingsszene, was hat euch am besten gefallen? Ja, der vollste. Die war gut. Genau wie es jetzt einen Reddit-Thread gibt, wo ich auch überlegt habe, mal reinzuschreiben. Nee, mache ich nicht. Irgendwann mal vielleicht. Nach ein paar Wochen kann man auch mal Story-Sachen beantworten. Und jetzt kommen die ganzen Logikfehler auf, die ihr alle übersehen habt, und die kommen jetzt aneinander. Genau, haben schon ein paar auf, würde ich gerne auf antworten, auf manche, weil natürlich manche sind uns auch schon aufgefallen, und da man sich schon Lösungen überlegt und so weiter, und hat schon in der Story versucht, dagegen zu arbeiten. Und da würde ich gerne auf ant Antworten, aber das mache ich erst nach ein paar Wochen. Ich finde, das muss erst ein bisschen, er soll es für sich sprechen, die Serie, und dann kann man dazu antworten. So hat das Rian Johnson von Star Wars 8 auch gehandhabt. Fand ich gut, guter Plan. Aber er hat dann irgendwann geantwortet. Irgendwann hat er nach ein paar Wochen geantwortet, ja. Und er hat dann gesagt, ja. Nee, das geht schon. Komm. Oft ist es Gif, wo John Travolta sich so umsieht im Club und nicht weiss, wo er ist und die Schultern zur Geste macht. Na ja. Jetzt komm, sei mal nicht so. Oder komm, war schon cool, oder? Aber die eine Szene war schon auch richtig geil. Ja, mit dem ... Nee, wie hast du vor, deinen Sommer zu verbringen? Wie ist das im Sommer? Heute sind so große Sommerpausenfolge. Nee, sehr entspannt tatsächlich. Und ich denke mir immer so, also diese Thematik Sonnenbrand und so, wo ich immer so ein bisschen versuche, jedes Jahr es ein bisschen besser zu machen. Weil meine Theorie, und sag mir, wenn sie falsch ist, ist so ein bisschen, man kann in dem Land, in dem man lebt, keinen Sonnenbrand bekommen. Ja, ist falsch. Gut. Weil ich denke mir, man ist ja daran gewohnt. Du kannst ja, wenn du in Afrika aufwächst, dann ist dein Körper ja die afrikanische Sonne gewohnt. Wohingegen, wenn du jetzt in Deutschland aufwächst und dann fährst du nach Afrika, dann ballert die dich weg, weil dein Körper ist einfach das nicht gewohnt. Weil dein Körper muss ja funktionieren in der Sonne. Du kannst ja, ja also ich meine wir sind jetzt zwar irgendwie verweichlichte 21 jahrhundert Menschen aber trotzdem der Körper wird ja nicht so schlecht sein dass er einfach sagt wie Sonne keine Sonne bitte keine Sonne so ich denke mir so da wo du aufgewachsen bist da passt das schon dachte ich auch mein Leben lang da bin ich neulich wie gesagt da war es ja richtig schön hier in Köln, schöner Sommertag, bin ich mit dem Fahrrad durch die Stadt gefahren.
Schön von Park zu Park, schön Picknickkorb dabei, wirklich einen tollen Sommertag hier in Köln gehabt.
Und nach Minute drei ist mir aufgefallen, warum ich das lange nicht mehr gemacht habe, nämlich weil die Allergie reingekickt hat.
Ah, deine Sonnenallergie.
Aber nee, nicht die Sonnenallergie, sondern ich glaube Pollen. Und das war wirklich lächerlich schlimm. Und ich dachte mir, aber ich wohne doch hier, das ist doch das Land, in dem ich geboren bin, das die Vegetation, mit der ich aufgewachsen bin, warum passiert das denn jetzt hier? Und dann wirklich, also meine Augen waren komplett rot, ich habe nichts mehr gesehen, alles ist angeschwollen, meine Rachen ist angeschwollen, ja und dann musste ich zur zur Notapotheke fahren. Notapotheke, M-Apotheke, T-Apotheke, T-Apotheke. Ja, so, dann bin ich in die Notapotheke gefahren und dann, ich dachte, okay, das ist eine Apotheke mit Notdienst, da ist halt jemand da, wo dann einfach reingehen kann. Das ist einfach eine offene Apotheke, es haben halt nicht alle offen. So, ich bin da reingegangen, wollte ich zumindest, Tür war verschlossen. Und dann saß eine Familie davor und da habe ich die gefragt, wie läuft das jetzt hier? Und dann haben die gesagt, nee, du musst da an dieses Fach, du musst da an dieser Klingeln, und dann macht er dieses Fach auf. Ich dachte, was ist jetzt los? Und dann war da so eine Notklingel und dann macht er so ein Notfach
auf und dann kommt der Notapotheker
und sagt, was ist denn ihr Notfall?
Und dann musst du sagen, ja so,
ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das als Notfall geht,
aber ich habe ganz rote Augen
bei Allergie und dann sagt er, ja okay,
dann habe ich dann meine Sachen bekommen
und dann hat er die zu diesem,
wie man das kennt, von so
manchen Zoos auch.
Oder wenn du irgendwo zu so einem Wahrzeichen gehst, wo Leute sitzen hinter so Glaskästen, schieben die dann diese Medikamente durch so ein Fach und dann klappen die das so auf und dann kannst du es da rausnehmen. Warum die Show, Leute? Warum die Show? Ihr seid einfach eine Apotheke, die offen ist. Warum, da ist jemand in der Apotheke drin. Mach die Tür auf. Warum musst du denn diese Show machen mit der Notfallglocke und dem Notfallkippsystem, mach die Apotheke einfach auf. Vielleicht damit die nicht ausgeraubt werden, oder, dass man da nicht so leicht einbringen kann. Was ist das Problem an einem Wochentag dann? Ja, an einem Wochentag ist ja die Polizei aktiv. Du meinst an diesen Anarchiefeiertagen oder Sonntagen, ist alles möglich. Da surft es einen anderen ein, dann so und die so. Heute ist es Wilder Westen, heute ist es Marie-Himmelfahrt. Passt schon. Ja, wie, was für ein Feiertag? Marie-Himmelfahrt. Marie. Tschüss. Ciao. Aber es ist schon merkwürdig. Aber das ist tatsächlich dieses, ab wann ist es ein Notfall. Ein Notfall ist ja auch höchst subjektiv. Natürlich, klar, Beinab ist ein Notfall, aber meine Nase läuft, kann natürlich ähnlich unangenehm sein. Ähnlich unangenehm sein, ja. In deinem eigenen Spektrum. Vielleicht hast du noch nichts Schlimmeres erlebt. Nee, für mich, Mittelstandskind, war es ein Riesenunglück in meinen roten Augen. Und dann bin ich da hin. Da meinten der, war aber für ihn ein total akzeptables Problem offensichtlich. Da habe ich für die Familie, die da saß davor, habe ich dann noch den Gag gemacht, dass ich mir jetzt noch ein Emoikal mitgeben lasse. Stell dir mal vor, du gehst zu der Notapotheke, du rüst die Klingel und bestellst einmal Lakritzschnecken. Diese leckeren Aprikosentrauben, Traubenzucker, bitte noch. Die, die auch noch. Ob der dann sagt, das ist die Notapotheke, und er sagt, klar, ich mache dann zwei Euro fünfzig, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Und dann hat die Familie doll gelacht. Herzlichen Dank, ein bisschen zu viel für meinen Geschmack. Vielleicht, ich meine, der kann ja da schlecht Nein sagen, oder? Ich meine, wenn er schon da ist und dann sagst du, ja, mein Nase läuft, und dann sagst du, das ist kein Notfall. Ja, wir sehen uns schon dieses Sie-Kipp-Ding geöffnet? Ich war in Vietnam. Ich wurde vom Moskito gebissen, während ich drei Schüsse in den Fuss bekommen habe. Dann kam ein Helikopter, dann ist er neben mir gelandet. Wind ins Gesicht, Staub, Sand im Gesicht, steigt er aus und sagt, hier ist ein Telefonat für Sie, ein Anruf, gehe ich ans Telefon, sag, hallo, guten Tag, wer ist da, oh, hier ist deine Frau, sämtliche unsere Kinder sind gestorben, alle weg, alle schön weg, alle im Wald weg, so, lege ich auf, sag, danke, tschüss, steigt wieder auf, Sand ins Gesicht, direkt, ja, noch mal drei Schüsse ins andere Bein, ich liege auf dem Boden, ja, kommen die Würmer auf mich drauf, Skorpion, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, beide Augen weggestochen. So, und jetzt kommst du hier an und erzählst mir, was von meiner Nase läuft oder was. Das ist doch kein Notfall. Das ist doch kein Notfall. Und einen Emoikal hätte ich gerne auch noch. Ja, die sind lecker. Die sind auch lecker. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich so das einzige... Unglaublich lecker. Und die gibt es auch sonst nirgendwo. Ich glaube, das ist der einzige, das ist der Haken, mit dem man Leute in der Apotheke bekommt. Emoikal. Ist einfach Emoikal. Emoikal schon, ne? Aber dann, und die Familie war davor so glücklich, danach, nach diesem Witz. Dein Eingeg von dir, es schafft diese Familie über Jahrzehnte hinweg in den Himmel zu. Die haben schon penetrant das Gespräch gesucht. Danach habe ich meinen Fahrrad genommen und bin weggefahren, ohne den Schiss zu sagen. Und dann, anderer Zeitpunkt des Tages, war ich in einem Park und habe mich neben so einem Typen gesetzt. Ich war nur mit anderen unterwegs und wir sassen auf so einer Bank. Und neben mir war ein Typ, der gerade so eine Bachelorarbeit geschrieben hat oder so was, so eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit, ist dafür in den Park gegangen, war schon nicht draußen. Und dann sind wir dem sehr auf die Pölle gerückt, weil er halt einfach da saß und die Bank nicht so groß war. Und dann ist er irgendwann aufgestanden, hat sich verabschiedet von uns. Und dann fiel mir die Familie ein, bei der ich nicht Tschüss gesagt habe. Und dann habe ich mir lange danach, jetzt wochenlang überlegt, wie, und das habe ich mich immer schon gefragt, wann sagt man Fremden Tschüss?
Nach welcher Interaktion oder welchem Grad der Annäherung muss stattgefunden haben, damit man einer fremden Familie oder einer fremden Person Tschüss sagt?
Das ist schon oft passiert, dass man nicht genau weiß, weil oft hat man mal zwei Sätze gewechselt mit jemandem gegenüber in der Bahn und dann sagt man auch Tschüss, wenn man geht. Man verabschiedet sich. Und die Familie war so glücklich, dass ich dachte, ich hätte Tschüss sagen sollen, das tat mir auch leid. Die waren bestimmt enttäuscht. Die Frage ist auch immer, ist ein Tschüss gerichtet von einem zum anderen? Also hat der eine die Verpflichtung, sich vom anderen zu verabschieden oder ist es, wenn dann eine beidseitige Verpflichtung? Ist es eine beidseitige wenn dann? Naja, aber zum Beispiel, wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, klassisch im ICE und jemand fragt, ey, kannst du mir helfen, meinen Koffer auf die Ablage zu tun? Dann tut der eine dem anderen ja einen Gefallen. Muss dann auch der, der geholfen hat, Tschüss sagen? Oder sagt dann sozusagen, der dem geholfen wurde Tschüss und der andere erwidert nur? Oder ist ist dann immer eine beidseitige? Mir ist das passiert, dass man am Anfang einer fünfstündigen Fahrt jemandem geholfen hat, dann fünf Stunden da saß und nicht begangen gesprochen hat und am Ende einen Tschüss bekommen hat. Wo ich dachte, wow, das ist so toll, dass es dann die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund noch war, diese Information. Ja, ich hatte ja auch mal, dass mir jemand, dass mir der Handschuh runtergefallen ist und der Gegenüber hat den Handschuh hochgehoben und hat mir gegeben und ich danke. Und dann saß ich wirklich zweieinhalb Stunden ihm gegenüber und dachte mir, soll ich mich jetzt verabschieden, wenn ich gehe oder nicht? Ja! Ja, wirklich zweieinhalb Stunden mir überlegt und bin zu keinem Ergebnis gekommen. Ich dachte mir, ich weiß es nicht genau. Doch, ich weiß es nicht. Und auch dieses Einschlafen ist auch so ein Ding, gerade in der S-Bahn, wenn der Gegenüber einschläft.
Und ich hatte auch nur, hab nur meine Augen ausgeruht irgendwie, lag da, also saß da und hat der andere mich auch so angedotzt und so, hey, nicht, dass du deine alte Stelle verpasst.
Wirklich?
Du sagst so aus, als würdest du schlafen.
Wie übergriffig ist das denn?
Naja, ist nett gedacht und nicht so, nee, ich fahre bis zur Endstation.
Nee, das war mir nicht gedacht.
Und dann hatte ich Angst, dass ich dann...
Wie übergriffig ist das denn?
Naja, der Gedanke...
Hey, sie, die vorstellen, dass da jemand die ganze Zeit durch den Zug läuft und Leute weckt.
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Also was, ich ruhe nur meine Augen aus.
Ja, aber ich meine, es ist natürlich schon nett, weil gerade, ich meine, ja klar, war natürlich ein bisschen Es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, meine, es ist natürlich schon nett, weil gerade, ich meine, ja klar, war natürlich ein bisschen abends, war halb elf, wenn ich unterwegs bin, da kann man schon mal nach einer durchzechten Nacht irgendwie dann so im Halbschlaf dann einfach einnehmen. Ein wandelnder Wecker. Ja, es ist was. Der Rumläufe heute andötzt oder was. Hey! Und das war auch so ein Ding, wo man dann auch nicht weiß, sagt man dann auch tschüss oder muss ich, da liegt die Last jetzt auf mir. Nicht tschüss sagen. Weil wenn der jetzt aufsteht und geht, dann ist er immer so ein bisschen so diese diese 30 Millisekunden. Wenn der jetzt einschläft, weil dann weißt du, was seine Vorstellung ist, was man machen sollte, wenn man schläft. Richtig. Und wir beide haben, glaube ich, die Ansicht, man sollte jemanden nicht wecken, wenn schlägt. Die Frage ist, ob er dann nicht so sensibilisiert ist fürs Thema zu früh einschlafen, dass er auf keinen Fall selber einschlafen würde, wenn er nicht bis zur Endstation fahren wollen würde. Oder das präventive Wecken war so eine Art Hilferuf. Ich weiss, ich schlafe auf jeden Fall ein, ich kenne jemanden, der wach ist, der aufpasst, dass ich nämlich meine Station verpasse. Das ist schwierig, aber tatsächlich in Endstationen, wenn jemand noch schläft, dann gebe ich denen so ein bisschen einen mit, wenn ich aussteige. Ja, aber kein aktives Wecken. Hallo, hallo, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Hallo. Ich würde deren Uhr nehmen und den Wecker stellen. Nee, aber ich mache mal beim Aufstehen so, streife ich die dann so ein bisschen. Aber mit dem Rack so ausversehen, so ein bisschen so, oh Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung. Aber wir sind auch jetzt da. Das Letzte, was du willst, ist, dass du weißt, dass du geweckt wurdest. Ja. Dass du dann so, ah jetzt, ja. Ja, stimmt schon. Es ist immer lustig, wenn man Leuten hier in Köln dann zum Beispiel bei der U-Bahn, die steigen dann ein und fragen dann meist auf Englisch, where is the, I don't know, Severinstrasse? Und ich sage, ja, da müssen so noch eight Stations fahren und dann sagen die thank you und du sagst please und dann ist man noch ewig lang in der gleichen Bahn. Ja, und dann fällt einem Fax die falsche Richtung. Naja, das wäre auch nicht so schlecht. Aber ich dachte jetzt eher an, man verbringt ja noch sehr viel Zeit im Zug, wo man nicht weiß, ist man jetzt schon, war schon die Hemmschwelle in Richtung Smalltalk, hat man schon jetzt eine gewisse Grenze überschrieben. Ja, genau. Weil nach einer gewissen Zeit kann man nicht noch mal anfangen zu reden. Es gibt Fenster. Es gibt Fenster, ja, und da muss man durchklettern. Durchsteigen? Oder sie schliessen Ach so. Je nachdem. Das offene Fenster habe ich als Metapher noch nie ganz verstanden. Ich auch nicht. Für wen offen? Luft? Für etwas. Aber irgendwann ist es zu. Warum ist es nicht Tür? Warum ist das offene Fenster nicht eine offene Tür? Ist das bessere Symbol? Ja, aber die Tür ist normalerweise zu. Ich glaube, Türen sind häufiger zu als Fenster. Auf gar keinen Fall. Doch, klar. Fenster sind meistens zu. Wie oft, wie viel Prozent der Zeit ist so eine normale Tür offen? 0,1% Aufzug? Alle meine Türen sind immer offen. Aufzugtüren. Fenster? Das ist eine spezielle Tür. Fenster sind immer zu. Aufzugtüren. Naja, aber jetzt so eine normale Tür halt hier, so die Tür jetzt. Die wurde seit Jahren nicht mehr geöffnet. Niemand weiß, was da dahinter ist. Hier ist das Lustigste aller Zeiten passiert. Wir sind ja im Schnittraum, ja. Und hier führt eine Tür ab. Und dahinter ist einfach ein Serverraum. Das ist ein Server, ja. Und dahinter ist eine ganz, das sieht man dem Raum auch an, eine ganz kleine Kammer. So ein Quadratmeter Kammer ist dahinter. Und wir saßen hier, hatten eine Schnittabnahme mit Netflix. Und wir saßen hier in diesem Raum und Netflix war da, aus L.A. gekommen. Wirklich? Echte Netflix-Amerikaner waren hier? Netflix-Amerikaner waren in diesem Raum. In diesem wir haben zusammen eine Folge geschaut. Und was ich ... Scooby-Doo. Und dann kam ... Ja, Fargo. Naja, und hier kam halt jemand rein. Davor kam Axel aus der IT rein, was niemand gesehen hat. Außer ich war schon im Raum. Aber Axel aus der IT kam rein und ist in diesen Raum gegangen, diesen Serverraum. Ja. Tür ging zu. Und dann war ich hier drin und ich musste schon
so irgendwie ein bisschen grinsen, weil ich
habe schon geahnt, was passiert. Aber dann kam
Netflix halt rein und wir
saßen halt hier ungefähr,
weiß nicht, eine Stunde
und haben halt die Folge geguckt und darüber
diskutiert und so weiter und saßen hier drin
und haben Stellen nochmal geschaut und so.
Und irgendwann ging die Tür auf und
Axel kommt raus und sagt Morning und geht halt raus und der ganze Raum war, what? Was ist gerade passiert? Der war eine Stunde in diesem Raum und es ist kein Raum, in dem er eine Stunde ist. Oh, ich hätte schon wieder voll vergessen, dass da jemand drin war. Und der ganze Raum war unfassbar verwirrt und like, did he sleep there? Weil ich wüsste auch nicht, wie es erklären sollte, dass er da offensichtlich einen Server repariert hat gerade. Und ich wollte auch nicht so viel Zeit da jetzt aufwenden, das zu erklären. Also habe ich dieses Rätsel nie aufgelöst. Und bis heute denken die, dass in der BTF Leute in Räumen, in Serverräumen schlafen. Das war sehr seltsam. Aber wie ist es, wenn man dann die Folge schaut? Schielt man dann immer so auf die Netflix-Leute und so, jetzt haben sie nicht gelacht bei dem Gag und so und so. Ich habe auch Dinge angelacht. Du hast einmal angelacht. Und ihr habt es dann auf Deutsch mit englischen Untertiteln geschaut. Ja, the thing is, sometimes the subtitles aren't ready yet. So, most of the time, the subtitles aren't ready yet. Or they're wrong. Ah, die sprechen ja kein Wort Deutsch, oder? No word. Das heißt, die schauen sich dann eine deutsche Folge an und checken gar nichts. Ja, doch, die kennen ja die Bücher und so und die wissen ja auch dann, die sind ja so sehr im Prozess drin, dass sie schon alles checken. Und die sind doch nicht doof. Aber die gucken dann eine Folge und viele Gags funktionieren einfach nicht, weil die Untertitel noch scheiße sind. Und es hilft dann auch nicht bei so einer Präsentation, dass plötzlich Axel aus dem Raum kommt und offensichtlich darin geschlafen hat. Müssen wir so eine Sonderfolge machen. Ich würde auch gerne Audiokommentare für die Folgen aufnehmen, um ehrlich zu sein. Ey, mach das, auf jeden Fall. Aber darfst du jetzt über alles sprechen eigentlich? Also alles, was in der ersten Staffel passiert ist, darfst du sprechen. Ja, machen wir mal irgendwann. Lass uns noch ein paar Wochen Zeit lassen, bis sie jeder geguckt hat. Genau, das kündigen wir auch an und dann könnt ihr eure ganzen Fragen einschicken, dann können wir das alles mal gebunden. Dann hast du es auch hinter dir, dann musst du nicht immer ständig überall. Man kann ja sagen, dass du auch in einem Projekt beteiligt warst. Ein bisschen. Ganz, ganz klein wenig. Ich war der Dota-Berater. Du warst der Dota-Berater, wobei wir haben jetzt viel Lob bekommen für die Code-Umsetzung. Ah, cool. Weil es sehr coole Codes sind, die nicht nur alle echt sind und auch alle theoretisch genauso einen Drogenshop kreieren könnten,
sondern auch gute Codes sind.
Also einfach, die machen Spaß, ich habe keine Ahnung davon, aber machen wohl...
Richtig launige Codes.
Machen wohl Spaß anzugucken.
Da geht wohl Mathematikern, Codern, ITlern geht das Herz auf.
Sehr schön.
Ja, das hat mich sehr gefreut.
Das ist doch schön, ja.
Nee, sehr spannend alles, können wir mal in Ruhe bequatschen. Bist du ein Coder? Ne, gar nicht, oder? Ich dachte immer, man sollte das eigentlich in unserem Alter und der Zeit, in der wir leben, sollte man eigentlich Codes, zumindest HTML sollte man checken und so ein bisschen CSS und so. So ein bisschen, also ich kann vielleicht empfehlen, es gibt zwei sehr, sehr gute Videospiele, so Rätsel-Knobelspiele, die einem so ein bisschen die Grundlagen vielleicht von Programmierung beibringen, aber jetzt nicht wirklich, aber so ein bisschen das Denken wie Programmier. Stimmt, wie heisst das? Human Resource Machine ist der erste Teil und dann Seven Billion Humans. Da muss man in so einer immer, immer komplexer werdenderen Programmiersprache Probleme lösen und es macht richtig viel Spaß. Und ich liebe diese Spiele, weil die werden richtig fucking schwer. Und ich liebe Spiele, wo man einfach weiss, du wirst definitiv an deine Grenzen kommen,
egal wie cool du denkst, dass du bist, es fängt total leicht an und es wird immer krasser und immer krasser und es ist wirklich macht gross und Spaß und du liest das Problem immer und du denkst dir, es ist unmöglich, es lässt sich nicht lösen, unmöglich und dann probierst du Sachen aus und du merkst, dass es geht und dann mit so einer ganz einfachen Programmiersprache kriegst du auch krasse Sachen hin. Das ist total faszinierend. Und also erster Teil Human Resource Machine, schaut es euch auf jeden Fall an. Ganz toll sind auch die Tiger-Team-Bücher von Thomas Brezina, wo man auch dann kleine Rätsel lösen kann. Das ist eine tolle, spannende Geschichte über fünf Freunde, das Tiger-Team, die Abenteuer lösen. Und es ist superschwer auch.
Und dann musst du auch dahinter kommen, dann hast du so eine kleine Lupe, die kannst du dann je nachdem, wie du aufs Buch hältst, kannst du dann die Lösung sehen.
Und am Ende kannst du dann eintragen, wie viel du richtig geraten hast und ob du ein gutes Tiger-Team-Mitglied wärst.
Oder du schaust auf der letzten Seite die Lösungen nach.
Oder du schaust die Lösungen nach, aber das macht man nicht, weil dann ist man gemeint.
Aber auch da kommst du definitiv an deine Grenzen, kann ich dir sagen. Aber was sind die Gegenspieler vom Tiger-Team nochmal?
Haben die nicht irgendwie so auch so ein ...
Team Rocket?
Team Roch Aber auch da kommst du definitiv an deine Grenzen, kann ich dir sagen. Aber was sind die Gegenspieler vom Tiger-Team nochmal? Haben die nicht irgendwie so auch so ein ... Team Rocket? Team Rocket oder sowas? Weiß ich nicht. Oh, ich weiß, Detective Pikachu. Ja? Ich war in dem Film, Kino. Schade. Ja? Ja, da war mehr drin. Die kämpfen ja nicht, die Pokémon, oder? Doch schon. Ja? Aber nicht schön. Und dann auch, also mein größter, ich habe die ganze Zeit auf der Aufstattung im Moment gewartet, weil ich dachte, das machen die doch, dass der Protagonist an irgendeinem Punkt ein Fahrradgeschenk bekommt, sich draufsetzt und die Bike-Musik angeht. Warum das kein Problem? Das ist doch das Erste. Also als Autor von einem, du darfst, das ist doch der beste Job der Welt, schreib mal einen Pokémon-Film, uns ist die Story scheißegal, es geht grob um Pokémon, viel Spaß, wow, da geht auch eine Welt auf,
da will ich erst mal eine Bucketlist machen mit Dingen, die ich auf jeden Fall unterbringen will,
wie zum Beispiel, dass jemand ein fucking Fahrer geschenkt bekommt und dann die Musik angeht von die beissige Musik. Genau, das hohe Gras generell, muss durchs hohe Gras laufen und jeder im Publikum
weiss, oh, oh, oh, Kleinstein. Ja, das haben wir soas generell, muss sich das hohe Gras laufen und jeder im Publikum weiss, oh oh oh,
Kleinstein. Ja, das haben wir so ein bisschen gemacht.
Aber die meisten Sachen haben sie nicht gemacht.
Die meisten Dinge, die Top Ten
in meinem Kopf haben, die nicht abgearbeitet. Schade.
Ich denke, da hätte ich so viel mehr drin gewesen.
Ein schöner Pokémon-Film. Muss ich noch anschauen,
habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen. Ist so ein Ding,
da warte ich auf iTunes. Echt ganz, ganz schlecht.
War ich kein großer Fan von.
Jetzt kriege ich wieder Gegenwind.
Naja, hey.
Du kennst dich jetzt offiziell aus.
Ist das so?
Ja.
Das ist lustig.
Du bist jetzt Insider.
Wenn du das sagst, dann okay.
Gut, der kennt sich ja auch.
Genauso bin ich Arme wie vorher, aber dann wird man so Kinopus eingeladen, hat jetzt eine
Serie geschrieben und deswegen hat man uns jetzt drauf.
Ja.
Du warst bei Kinoplus?
Nee.
Mal.
Bei der Binge.
Ach so.
Bei der Binge war ich jetzt zu Gast.
Ja, könnt ihr gerne mal angucken.
Würde mich freuen.
Das war's für heute. uns jetzt drauf. Ja, du warst bei Kino Plus? Nee, mal. Bei der Binge war ich jetzt zugeist, ja, könnt ihr gerne mal angucken, würde mich freuen. Lasst ein Like da und sagt man das noch? Einen guten Kommentar. Sagt man das noch? Ja, ich glaube schon. Ist der Algorithmus mittlerweile so komplex? Ja, das ist immer so ein bisschen so ein Ding, angeblich ist es ja alles jetzt so Machine Learning mässig, dass sozusagen die Leute von YouTube gar nicht mehr wissen, wie der Algorithmus direkt funktioniert. Bei Machine Learning gibst du ja nur vor, was ist das Ziel. Und dann, welche Parameter der Algorithmus verwendet und wie stark der welche gewichtet, probiert er halt aus und schaut dann, was am besten funktioniert. Und du sagst ihm nur, was ist das Ziel, möglichst viele Minuten sollen die Leute auf YouTube bleiben. Was sie anschauen, ist uns scheißegal. Und dann auch völlig egal, aus aus welchen Kategorien, und dann probiert der Algorithmus das halt so aus, ja, jetzt gebe ich dem erst so ein Video oder so ein Video. Also ergeben sich doch dann im schlimmsten Fall einfach ja Nordkorea-Dokus. Ja, genau, ja klar. YouTube ist ja egal, und deswegen kriegt man auch teilweise verrückte Videos in die... Die man aber anklickt, weil es genau passt. Die man anklickt, wo jetzt ein Mensch sagen würde, das passt jetzt nicht zusammen. Kennt YouTube dich besser als du selbst? Ja, könnte man sagen, aber eigentlich kennt er dich ja gar nicht, der weiß nur, was vor dir schon viele Menschen ähnlich gemacht haben, und er geht dann davon aus, dass du es auch so machen wirst. Das heißt, eigentlich kennt er nur alle vor dir gut und denkt, du wirst wahrscheinlich genauso funktionieren wie alle anderen. Und deswegen ist dieses ganze Lastenkommi da so ein bisschen, man weiß einfach nicht genau, was funktioniert. Vielleicht kann man selber so ein bisschen experimentieren und sagen, lange Videos sind besser als kurz, aber man weiß ja nicht, ob es daran liegt. Vielleicht lag es an was ganz anderem, vielleicht lag es daran, dass in den ersten drei Minuten ganz oft die Farbe rot war. Vielleicht achtet der Algorithmus darauf, weil er gemerkt hat, aus irgendeinem Grund ist das das, was Leute dazu bringt, mehr Videos zu schauen, weiss kein Mensch. Noch weiss niemand. Aber so habe ich es zumindest mal gelesen, ich weiss, ob das stimmt. Aber deswegen gibt es ganz viele Leute, die generell bei YouTube gab es immer schon ganz viele Leute, die behauptet haben, man hinter das geknackt, den Algorithmus zu knacken. Und ich glaube, die lagen immer falsch. Ich glaube, weil der Algorithmus aber auch diese Videos guckt und sagt, nö, dann nicht, dann mache ich das anders. Wir hatten ja tatsächlich bei, nach der FrankElster-Masterclass hatten wir ja Sujo-TV eine kurze Zeit. Und da hatten wir auch viel Kontakt zu solchen Leuten, die, also Business Insider, die sich halt auskennen, die so, ja, wir ficken eure Seite nach vorne und so. Und da hatten wir dann Leute, die dann auch gemeint haben, so, ja, also, ich hab den YouTube-Algorithmus so gut verstanden, ich könnte auch ein schwarzes Video auf die YouTube-Startseite bringen.
Also ein komplett leeres Video.
Und ich mache das.
Mach doch mal.
Hast du es schon mal gemacht? Nee, aber könnte ich.
Nee, aber ich habe jetzt hier auch kein Internet.
Doch, wir haben Internet.
Wir haben genug Schwarz.
Wir haben sehr viel Schwarz, wir haben Internet.
Volles Schnittprogramm. WLAN-Passwort habe ich dir gar nicht gegeben.
Ja, nee, da muss ich erst mit meinem Network. Mit was? Das ist ja alles netzvernetzt heutzutage. Ja. Mit Cloud-Servern und so. Haben wir ja auch alles. Kannst du dich auch hier einloggen. Ja, ja, ja. Daraus kommst du nur mit mehr Begriffen. So wie Blockchain. Du, ja genau, du musst einfach all den. Internet of Things und so, und dann kommst du langsam raus. Tatsächlich hatten wir uns mit dem zu einem Mittagessen getroffen, an dem Tag, als mein linkes Ohr zugeschwollen war, und der Typ sass links von mir, und ich musste immer so mich so im Restaurant umschauen, um so mein rechtes Ohr in dessen Nähe zu bringen, weil ansonsten, wenn dieses Gespräch sehr unangenehm wurde, weil es gibt ja manchmal so Zuschwollen war. Ja, ich hatte so eine Gehörgangsentzündung und dann war das so angeschwollen halt ein bisschen und war halt zu. Oh Gott, oh was. Ja, unangenehm, aber das Problem ist auch, wenn man eine Seite hat, wird dadurch die andere auch entzündet. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das geht, dass die so einmal so außenrum gehen, aber es gibt ja manchmal so Gesprächspartner, die aus irgendeinem Grund immer dich anschauen,
wenn sie reden. So, du triffst dich mit einer Gruppe
von fünf Leuten. Oh, ich glaube, das ist bei dir ein Ding,
weil du prominent bist, kannst das glaube ich nicht.
Ja, aber damals ja auf gar keinen Fall. Ach so, meinst du das?
Und wenn einfach so fünf Leute sitzt du vor dir und
der redet nur mit dir und denkst dir, was
muss ich tun, um das abzuschütteln?
Ich hatte mal eine Musiklehrerin, die
mich immer eingeguckt hat, aber
beziehungsweise immer den,
also wenn zwei Leute zu dir gekommen sind,
immer den eingeguckt hat, bei dem sie leider nicht spricht,
Was ich... Ich hatte mal eine Musiklehrerin, die mich immer angeschaut hat, aber beziehungsweise immer den, also wenn zwei Leute zu ihr gekommen sind, immer den angeschaut hat, bei dem sie gar nicht spricht, was sie wahnsinnig arrogant gemacht hat immer, weil sie immer so ein, also sie antwortet, aber sagt, ja was soll das denn sonst sein und guckt halt aber den anderen an und man als Fragesteller denkt man die ganze Zeit, was soll das denn sonst sein, bitte antworten, ist das ein A-Dur, ja was was soll das sonst sein? Das ist ein G oder B-Hess-Moll-Sieben oder was. Das ist dann immer so arrogant. Aber ich kenne das auch. Es gibt aber auch Menschen, das ist mir auch aufgefallen, bei Partys gibt es immer das eine Pärchen, was kommt, den ganzen Abend über nichts sagt, sich verabschiedet und nach so Guckpärchen. So ein Pärchen, was schon oft sehr lange zusammen ist, was abends irgendwo hinkommt, nebeneinander sitzt, sich die ganze Zeit abend nur umguckt, sich so ein bisschen berieseln lässt. So als ob sie sich den Fernseher anmachen und gucken. Ja, zum Glück müssen wir uns nicht unterhalten. Genau. Reden keinem auch miteinander. Irgendwann kommt dann so ein, wollen wir los, ja, ja, stehen auf und am nächsten Tag kriegen wir noch so eine Mail oder SMS für ein, danke für den tollen Abend mässig, das war gestern echt toll, müssen wir häufiger machen. und so ist mir nur häufig begegnet, diese Art Mensch, dieses Pärchen, was lange zusammen ist,
sich nichts zu sagen hat,
und ich frage mich dann mal, wie die auch dann, wie die leben,
ob die auch
zu Hause so miteinander sind, oder ob es einfach
24, 7 die leben. Ob die auch zu Hause so miteinander sind oder ob es einfach 24-7 Orgwood Silence. Viele Rituale halt so. Und gehst du jetzt einkaufen oder ich? Ja, ich. So ein durchritualisiertes Leben. Ja, wahrscheinlich. So viele Automatismen. Ja, einfach viele Routine. Aber ich weiß es nicht. Das ist schon so interessant. So Guckpärchen, die gucken einfach rum. Und ich habe immer das Gefühl, ich muss sie unterhalten. Und man denkt sich so, einer von den beiden will nicht hier sein. Wer ist es? Einer von beiden. Du kannst Fangfragen in den Raum werfen und dich so offenbaren. Ey, wollen wir noch rüber in den Club? Ja. Meist gucken die dann aber nur rum. Ja, das stimmt. Gucken ist super. Ach Gucken ist super. Also wenn du nicht mitreden musst und einfach nur gucken kannst, ist schon super perfekt. Das ist sehr einfach schon erkannt. What men love doing is walking around, looking around. Ja. Walking around, looking around. Just looking at things. Ich finde das echt gut. Einfach rumlaufen und gucken. Ist perfekt. Ist perfekt. Und sobald jemand die Frage stellt, und was gucken wir als nächstes an? Raus. Ist alles kaputt. Ja. Weil es geht nicht darum, was gucken wir jetzt an. Du guckst halt an, was da ist. Die komplette Abstinenz irgendeines Programms ist das, was es attraktiv macht. Und einfach so, guckt mir halt das an. Und dann sagt, wie, ihr wart in Rom und habt das nicht gesehen. Nee, nee. Walking around, looking around. Walking around, walking around. Und wenn ich irgendwie nur in einem Supermarkt bin, ja, das ist halt das, was ich hier angucke. Ich bin großer Fan von sich treiben lassen. Ja. In einfach mal, in fremden Städten ist es besonders toll. Grob wissen, wo man wohnt, reicht aus und einfach mal losziehen. Losziehen, und das mache ich in New York, das werden wir auch dieses Jahr in New York wieder machen. Ja. sich einfach treiben lassen und abends dann mit einer viel zu teuren Taxifahrt nach Hause, wenn man dann doch in Queens gelandet ist. Aber das immer mal mit dem Treiben lassen, gucken, mal essen gehen, wo man gerade ist. Sich auch nicht rechtfertigen müssen, einfach so, ach, jetzt gehe ich nach links. Lebensmittelvergiftung, weil du bei einem weirden Chinesen gelandet bist, okay, die nehmen wir mal mit. Und einfach sagen, ich gehe einfach genau dahin, wo ich gestern auch schon war. Und nicht wie nochmal dahin, ja, nochmal. Das ist auch das Ding beim Treiben lassen, du treibst dann auch oft in die gleichen Ecken. Klar, natürlich. Muss man auch sagen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber das ist ja auch nicht schlecht. Aber es wissen die Chinesen besser, wegen Mobike, wie Menschen dich treiben lassen in der Stadt. Werbung. Oh, Stefan, du, ich muss dir eins sagen, ey, ich habe komplett den Überblick über sämtliche medizinische Daten und Termine und so vergessen. Hä? Aber du weißt, wann dein nächster Check-Up ist beim Arzt oder was? Keine Ahnung. Wann wurde ich gegen was geimpft? Keine Ahnung. Ich habe völlig den Anschluss verloren. Weißt du was? Ich habe vielleicht die Lösung für dich. Wirklich? Ja, die TK-Safe-Funktion, der TK-App, die Technikerkrankenkasse, fantastische Krankenkasse mit einer tollen App.
TK heißt Technikerkrankenkasse?
Ja, und zwar haben die jetzt die neue TK-Safe-Funktion herausgebracht, wo wirklich alle deine Gesundheitsdaten drin sind.
Das ist ja schon nützlich zu wissen, weil zum Beispiel wenn man zu viele Antibiotika in kurzer Zeit nimmt, dann kann es ja auch wirklich gefährlich werden.
Du kannst dir erst einen Blick haben, wann du deine letzten Antibiotika verschrieben bekommen hast.
Echt? Ich hasse das, wenn Ärzte mich was fragen und ich habe keine Ahnung. Wann wurden sie zuletzt Tetanus geimpft? Keine Ahnung. Aber mit der TK-Safe-App ist das gar kein Problem mehr. Dann antwortet die App sozusagen für mich. Naja, die App hat alles im Griff für dich. Das ist eine eigene Krankheitsakte, die du einfach in deiner Tasche hast. TK-Safe ist also die App, die du brauchst, wenn du vergesslich bist, nicht weißt, wann der nächste Arzttermin ist oder du überhaupt nicht mehr weißt, welche Medikamente, die zuletztrieben wurden. Also, wie viele Tausend Euro kostet dieses TK Safe? Nee, ist komplett kostenlos. Komplett kostenlos? Naja, wenn du als Mitglied der TK bist. Alle Infos findet ihr einfach bei einer simplen Onlinesuche nach TK Safe mit F. Werbung. Ich verstehe die Existenz von Reisebüros nicht mehr.
Das sieht man noch so häufig.
Alte Leute, Rentner.
Das sieht man noch so häufig, aber das ist doch wirklich das Dümmste der Welt, da hinzugehen.
Doch, Senioren, und dann, oh, wo ist sicher? Ja, Malle.
Wo ist sicher? Ja, das stimmt, das ist auch so eine Frage, ne?
Wo ist, und dann meint man, ich komme mit der Rückfrage, wegen Wetter jetzt oder Sicherheit?
Nee, Terroristen.
Nee, wo ist das Wetter sicher? Sicher gut, ist auch eine Frage.
Ja, ja, ja. Wo ist das Wetter sicher gut?
Nicht auf diesem Planeten leider, das haben wir noch nicht geschafft.
Wo ist hundertprozentig Morgensonne?
Peru?
Peru.
Hauptstadt von Peru? Ah, Palanto. Wissendes Nicken, ja. Gut gemacht. Stimmt schon. Habt ihr viel beigebracht dann doch über die Jahre? Ja, doch, ich bin auch, ich glaube, ich kann mich jetzt fast von dir emanzipieren. Ich glaube, ich kann mich endlich von deiner Brust losreißen. Ich glaube, es geht wieder. Wann dann triecht der Brust losreißen.
Hinterlässt ein klaffendes Loch.
Glaubst du, du musst dieses Loch füllen?
Mit deiner Scheisserie?
Ich glaube, das ist ein großes Ding,
was lustigerweise wäre mir ...
Da will ich hier sehen.
Wow.
Das ist ein Problem.
Du hast das Konzert-Podcast verstanden, Stefan. Schweigen, genau. Guck Pärchen. Nee, ich glaube tatsächlich, das ist ein Problem von Trichterbrustbesitzern. Die wollen das Loch irgendwie füllen mit Dingen, mit Overachievement und so. Und die Frage ist, konnte die Serie jetzt mal ein Loch füllen? Nein, die Antwort ist nein. So wie Tony Stark eigentlich, der hat doch auch so ein Kristall da vorne drin. Genau, das passt mir auch rein. Gibt es doch bestimmt Cosplay oder so, dass man dann so leuchtende Sachen auf der Brust vorne hat. Das wäre bei mir mega. Wie machst du das so? Dann sage ich, ich habe das eine Behinderung. Oder so dieses Alien aus dem Film Alien, wo dieses Alien aus dem Brustkorb herausspricht. Stimmt. Rauskrabbel kann man bei mir bestimmt gut machen.
Hallo! Ja, das ist ja jetzt meine
große Challenge, ich mache jetzt viel Sport und will besser aussehen.
Meine Frage ist, wie gut kann ich
aussehen mit Trichterbrust? Und ich glaube,
die Grenze ist relativ schnell erreicht.
Das ist halt genau das Problem.
Übrigens, vielen, vielen Dank für die vielen Nachrichten
von meinen Trichterbrust-Brothers
da draußen, Brothers und Sisters.
Mehr Brothers tatsächlich.
Ist, glaube ich, auch verbreitet unter Männern.
Für Frauen ist es auch nicht schön,
Trichterbrust zu haben,
weil es ja auch da, die Brust halt auch
ein größeres Geschlechtsmeldmal ist.
Aber, also
vielen Shoutout an alle,
hang in there,
wir schaffen das, wir stehen das durch
und wir müssen dazu stehen.
Und viele Leute haben mir Nachrichten geschrieben,
dass sie jetzt offen damit umgehen wollen.
Und hier ist es ein, das durch und wir müssen dazu stehen. Ja. Und viele Leute haben mir Nachrichten geschrieben, dass sie jetzt offener damit umgehen wollen.
Wie machen sie das?
Häufiger mal oberkörperfrei.
Ach so.
Ab und zu mal ein Instagram-Foto.
Ja.
Dies machen unsere richtig bebrusteten Kollegen ja auch. Warum soll es denen vorbehalten sein?
Vielleicht ist das sogar der Normalzustand und es haben mehr Leute Trichterbrust als normal. Die denken einfach nur, sie sind falsch und haben sich versteckt. Ja, weil die anderen offen damit umgehen. Wir drehen den Spieß um. Das ist zu viel von der Brust. Das ist ganz gerade. Das ist absurd. Wir haben uns auch noch nie nackt gesehen. Nee, ganz bewusst. Glaubst du, es würde etwas ändern? Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, es würde einiges klären. Ich glaube, es würde einiges erklären. Ja, ich glaube, ich auch. Ich glaube, ich habe tatsächlich keinen einzigen meiner Freunde jemals nackt gesehen. Oh, das ist eine gute Frage. Glaube ich nicht. Also ich glaube, es ist so, wenn man so aus dem Sportkontext kommt, so dann Duschen, nach dem Training und so. Ich glaube, es macht total viel mit dir. Total. Wenn du damit offen umgegangen bist in der Jugend. Vor allem in der Zeit, wo es darum geht auch, also so in der Pubertät, ab 14 oder so. Wenn du da noch Sport gemacht hast und Gemeinschaftsduschen, ist glaube ich schon was, was mit dir, was offener dich umgehen lässt mit Sexualität in deinem Körper. Ich habe nur Sport gemacht, tatsächlich bis man duschen musste. Nicht deswegen, aber ich glaube so altersmäßig genau davor. Ja. Vor der E-Jugend. Ich war noch bei den Minis und E-Jugend dann nicht mehr. Dann habe ich Karate gemacht, aber da haben wir uns so wenig bewegt, dass wir uns nicht duschen mussten. Dafür sehr oft sehr intim angefasst. Ja, das stimmt. Viele Karate-Filme geschaut einfach. Das war unser Training. Hauptsächlich unser Training, ja. Nein, stimmt nicht. Wir haben schon gekämpft. Wir bringen den kleinen Plotin jetzt schon ein bisschen länger hierhin. Wir haben uns gefragt, warum denn noch nicht so viele Bewegungen kam. Komisch eigentlich, also unser, also wir haben jetzt den Lehrer aus Taiwan, Mr. Lee aus China, der hat eigentlich jetzt in den letzten Teilen, also der hat eine dreiteilige Trainingssession gemacht, also Mr. Lee, Mr. Lee, genau, ja, Fight of the Dragon, Fist of the Dragon und genau, mit Chuck Norris der Dritte. Das war eigentlich...
Ja, dann kommt das ja vielleicht noch.
Ja, nee, klar, muss man ein bisschen anfangen einfach.
Er ist auch vielleicht ein bisschen zu...
Also er hat zu viele Gürtel an.
Vielleicht hindert ihn das zu.
Zu viele Gürtel?
Richtig, aber eigentlich ist er ein Gürtel pro Person.
Ach, das kommt immer dazu.
Nee, nee, nee, nicht ein pro Mal, wo man da ist, sondern die Farben hoch. Ja, okay, gut. Völlig falsche Farben bei ihm, völlig falsche Farben, vollkommen durch die Bank. Und korrigiert das auch gar nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht, wo sie die her haben, weil das sind Karate-Gürtel schon, aber das sind völlig falsche Farben, also da sind teilweise auch sehr obszöne Motive drauf. Ja. Warum sind die her? Was ist das? Ne, Mann, das ist so ein Laden. Da haben wir es. Gut, alles klar. Dann bis nächste Woche. Tschüss Timmy. Tschüss Timmy. Ciao. Mein Karatelehrer hat immer gesagt, wenn man nicht so boxen musste, und dann so, Mensch, du bist doch ein kräftiger Typ, du kannst doch zuhauen. Das ist nur fett, ich bin nicht stark. Du bist ein kräftiger Typ. Ich bin nur fett. Sie verstehen nicht, wie Muskeln funktionieren. Die sollten wissen, wie Muskeln funktionieren sie mit dem Sportunterricht. Ach ja. Das waren schon krasse Leute, ne? So ein Karate, die dann noch als Erwachsenen... Ich hab ein-, zweimal beim Judo mitgemacht. Wo er auch am Anfang so komische Verbeugungen macht und sich hinkniet an so einen komischen Gott, den man gar nicht kennt, an den man gar nicht glaubt, anbeten muss und sagt, danke für das du mir ein Gürtel gegeben hast oder was sagt man da, weiß ich nicht. Man muss dann auch immer so erst mit dem, ich glaube, erst mit dem linken Fuss steht man auf und dann mit dem rechten, weil du hast ja das Schwert an der Seite, das heißt, wenn du erst mit rechts aufstehst, dann behindert dich das Schwert auf dem Boden, das heißt, du musst erstens links aufstehen und ich dachte mir so, dann, ich hätte jetzt lieber ein Schwert, also dann gehe ich lieber in Schwert, wie cool das ist, also die Leute zu motivieren, ja und nicht zu schnell umdrehen, sonst fällt die Pistole aus der Seite. Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, was das? Genau, also bei dem, also Vorsicht sein, dass die Hüfte nicht so schnell sich bewegt, sonst fliegt die Handgranate weg und fliegt die Pistole raus. Wow. Ja, weil traditionelle asiatische Kämpfer hatten immer hier die Pistole und die Handgranate. Und so Ninja-Sternenfeilen? Genau, die komplett hier an der Seite. What? Deswegen darf man sich auch nie rechts auf die Seite legen. Das will ich machen. Wie? Das will ich machen. Nee, wir machen hier Boxen. Lass es werfen. Nee, nee, wir machen hier nur Boxen. Lass es Handgranaten werfen und diese Pfeile werfen. Nee, nee, wir machen nur Boxen. Fussfeile auch, Giftfeile? Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, bitte. Nee, du darfst nie die rechte Hand hochtun, weil das ist, wenn du mit dem Bogen schießt. What, Bogen? Wie gesagt, wir machen nur das Schlagen hier. Das ist einfach
die schlechteste Werbung.
Das ist wie die Judo-Wallel dich grauenhaft.
Und es riecht nach Fuss. Das ist nämlich das,
was mich am meisten geärgert hat. Es riecht die ganze Zeit nach Fuss.
Und da muss der Mensch auch mal
zugeben, dass man auch mal
die Söckchen anlässt.
Weil Judo-Hallen riechen nach Fuss.
Das hat, glaube ich, noch niemand jemals
auf den Aufraus gesprochen. Aber es ist das größte Problem für mich gewesen beim Judo, waren nicht die Würfe, waren nicht die blauen Flecken, waren nicht die bunten Gürtel, nein, Fuss. Es riecht nach Fuss. Kann man da nicht irgendwie so Duftbäume verteilen oder am Anfang durch so ein Wasserbecken gehen oder so? Ja, ohne Scheiss. Aber das ist der menschliche Fuss, ist nicht dafür gemacht, mehr offen herum exponiert zu sein.
Das ist der Fuss, der offen herum exponiert zu sein. Der Fuß gehört jetzt auch in den Socken. Der Fuß ist eh kompletter Quatsch, finde ich. In Socken und Schüchen. Der Affe hat ja Hände an den Füssen. Geil. Dann kann man sich an den Füssen festhalten. Ja, nicht schon Hände an den Füssen. Dann kann man sich an den Füssen festhalten. Aber dann über die Evolution, ja, anscheinend wurden die Finger immer kürzer an den Füssen. Aber den letzten Rest hat dann die Evolution gesagt, nee, der bleibt, oder? Die letzten fünf Stummel, die bleiben schon. Die bleiben. Warum? Warum sind die nicht auch weg einfach? Dass man einfach so, zack, braucht man die? Das weiß ich auch nicht genau. Ich kann die auch gefühlt nicht mehr so richtig bewegen. Oder kannst du die wirklich genau so filigran bewegen? So als Ensemble kann man die bewegen. Ja, als Ensemble, aber immer nur als Gruppchen. Alle runter, alle hoch. Ich würde behaupten, du hast ein Duo und ein Trio. Ich kann das ganze Ensemble auch nicht bewusst ansteuern. Gewisse Gruppen. Ja, genau, Gruppen. Den grossen Zeh und der Rest zieht so nach. Aber es ist alles sehr unkoordiniert und falsch. Es wird auch so, als ob der Körper dann gesagt hat, komm, das ist auch nicht mehr so wichtig da jetzt in kleinen Zehen, besonders zu, den kannst du nicht heben. Ja, vor allem sind das starke, das sind doch sehr schwache Muskeln, oder? Weil ich meine, kann man sich nicht sparen? Ich habe zum Beispiel diese letzten... Man kann sich stark trainieren. Diese Free-Solo-Doku von diesem Free-Climber, der hat ja extrem starke Hände auch. Und der war bei Jimmy Kimmel oder so. Und ich konnte kein Wort von dem, was er gesagt hat, verstehen, weil ich nur auf seine Hände gestarrt hatte, weil der wirklich doppelt so große Hände hat wie ein ... Also von seiner Statur ist er ja relativ schmächtig. Er ist natürlich sehr kräftig und auch Muskeln, aber jetzt nicht so Bodybuilder-mäßig, sondern halt so sehnlicher. Aber wie meinst du, einfach lange Finger oder was? Nee, also das ist ja ... Weil die Hand, das sind ja auch alles Muskeln. Alles, was du bewegen kannst, ist ja per Definition Muskel. Also kann das ja auch trainiert werden und dicker werden als Muskel. Also kann die Hand ja einfach dicker werden. Er hätte Wurstfinger. Nicht Wurstfinger, aber halt einfach große Hände. Im Sinne von? Weil der hat ja teilweise seinen gesamten Körper an zwei Fingern hängen, wenn der da klettert und dann nicht mehr da reinkommt. Und der hat auch so eine Trainingsstange, wo er mit einzelnen Fingern Klimmzügen macht. Ich glaube jetzt nicht mit einem, vielleicht mindestens drei oder so. Es ist brutal, aber ich meine, das ist schon krass. Ja, auch dann, ich glaube, kannst du dann deine Nasenflügel zum Beispiel, kannst du trainieren, dass du da irgendwann so... Wahrscheinlich schon. Ich glaube sowieso, du kannst dein Gesicht komplett ändern, dadurch, dass du die einzelnen Muskeln trainierst. Ja, vielleicht kann man das. Viel Lächeln. Lächeln löst ja auch Gehirnglückshormone aus, weil das Gehirn hat sich ja gemerkt, was die Reaktion ist auf Serotonin, Dopamin, nämlich dass gewisse Muskelgruppen... Oh, da kommt der Drogenexpert wieder raus. Da müssen Drogen, äh, Muskelgruppen angesteuert werden, wenn dann diese Muskelgruppen Hey, brauchst du was? Ich habe ein bisschen was da. Ah, okay. Aber bleibt unter uns. Ja, ist okay. Gib mir was. 50 Euro? Lächeln. Ist jetzt der neue heiße Scheiss. Kompl komplett synthetisch, ja, komplett. Was?
Lächeln.
Wie Lächeln?
Dopamin, ja, Zilpamin, Seraphin, alles am Start.
Okay, ne, gib mal, Molly oder? Okay, 50 Euro, 50 Euro einmal lächeln, ohne Scheiss, Alter, es ballert dich weg, du bist komplett weg fürs ganze Wochenende, ohne Scheiss. Wie, ich stehe, ich versuche... Hey, hey, scht, Alter, hey, ruhig, Mann.
Ja, okay.
Okay?
Gut.
Fünft sich auch. Einsteigerpass, nur für dich, weil du so ein geiles...
Weil ich so ein geiles Lächeln habe?
Ja. Okay, fünft sich auch. Alles, okay. Okay? Gut. Einsteigerpass, nur für dich, weil du so ein geiles... Weil ich so ein geiles Lächeln habe? Ja. Okay, fühlst du dich auch. Alles klar. Lächel mal. Okay. Geil, oder? Ja, ich merke noch nichts. Du musst ein bisschen länger. Wie lange? Wie lange muss ich jetzt warten? Ja, ja, ja, mach mal so eine Woche. Eine Woche? Ja, und dann ballert das richtig rein, Mann. Ich hab morgen arbeiten, ich kann ja nicht so rumlaufen. Nee, nee, das ballert richtig rein. Also was arbeitest du? Comedian. Deswegen kenne ich dich nicht. Stand-up-Comedian. Stern-up-Comedian? Stand-up-Comedian. Wie die Sterne, oder was? Wurde, als Stand-up-Comedian weiß ich, dass es lustiger gewesen wäre, wenn ich gesagt hätte, weiß ich nicht, jemand der Leute beerdigt oder Notart oder so. Sorry, sorry, grobe Sorry. Ich merke was. Alles klar, ballert rein. Ja, ballert rein, geil, echt glücklich. Hattest du den Kontakt zu Drogendienern für Research? Ja. Hast du die gefunden? Die waren dann doch einfacher zu finden, ja. Über Leute, die man dann kennt, die hier in der Firma. Und so haben wir dann auch ein paar Drogendealer interviewt. Hat sich auch mal die Polizei bei euch gemeldet? Wir haben uns bei der Polizei gemeldet manchmal. Ach so. Für Fragen, wann die ... Eins, eins, und jetzt noch mal ... Äh, puh, was war das noch mal? Ähm, eins, eins ... Sorry, ich hab's gleich. Irgendwas, wie heißt es denn? 1,16, 1,16 ist die Kartensperrnummer. 1,16, das war's. Ja, 1,16, weiss ich ja. Krieg ich nicht mehr zusammen. Genau, mit dem haben wir manchmal gesprochen, wann gewisse Drogen strafbar sind und so weiter. Wie viel Menge, das ist ja auch immer so eine Menge. Wie viel Menge, genau, den Begriff des Eigenbedarfs und so was. Aber was heißt denn Menge? Also wenn du jetzt viele kleine Mengen hast. Ist das deine Menge, ja. Die fassen wir schon zusammen als Gesamtmenge. Also ich meine, in welchem räumlichen Kontext müssen diese einzelnen Mengen sein? Dein Besitz ist, glaube ich, interessant. Ich glaube, die räumliche Zugehörigkeit ist, glaube ich, relativ sekundär. Ja, aber an der Uhr hast du jetzt ein Kilo Koks. Nehmen wir so an, das ist zu viel. Dann machst du jetzt hundertzehn Gramm Päckchen. Ja. Und die verteilst du halt. An wen? Ja, halt. Gehören die noch dir? Die gehören mir, aber die sind eine Partei. Ja, aber die findet man ja nicht, weil die halt alle,
und dann habe ich eine große Schatzkarte,
aber dann sage ich nie, zehn Gramm ist Eigenbedarf.
Aber wir haben diese Karte gefunden mit diesen roten Kreuzen,
die bei Köln verteilt. Ja, die verbrennt man, während die Polizei an der Tür klopft.
So.
Was brennt denn da in dem Garten?
Nichts.
Herr Qualsdorf, ist das eine Schatzkarte?
Nein!
Gehen Sie mal vom Fenster weg, sie fallen noch runter, Herr Oberkommissar. Nee, das ist dann deine Menge, ja. Aber warum verteilt man die nicht so ein bisschen? Ich glaube, das wird auch gemacht. Es ist ganz interessant, mit Dealern zu sprechen, weil die nicht so schlau sind, glaube ich, wie sie manchmal denken, dass sie sind. Und dann hat einer gesagt, und wir schreiben auch nie über Fuffi oder so im Chat, wir sagen dann sowas wie Fuchs. Und man will den die ganze Zeit sagen, niemand spricht. Ich weiß nicht, in welcher Welt ihr lebt, aber bei uns in der echten Welt schreibt niemand über Füchse. Füchse sind kein Thing. Zehn Gramm für einen Fuchs, okay, Zwinker, Zwinker. Ja genau, was genau denkt der Ermittler, was da passiert? Die verkaufen Füchse, was soll das sein? Ich wollte ihm kurz sagen, niemand spricht über Füchse. Wohin ging Fuchshändler, sehr, sehr einfach unterzutauchen, sehr einfach unterzutauchen. Ja, genau. Das finde ich immer das Lustigste daran, dass wir, viele sagen, ihr verherrlicht Drogen in eurer Serie und so weiter. Ich finde viel interessanter, dass wir Leuten, die wirklich jetzt danach suchen wollen, wie man Drogen im Internet verkauft, das Leben zur Hölle machen. Weil erst drei Seiten Torrents und Artikel und Interviews und Bilder kommen, wo man dann wirklich ins Detail gehen muss, um nicht nur Sachen zur Serie zu finden. How to sell drugs online fast? No, really, I need it. Not the show. Not Netflix, please.
I really want to know how it's done. Fast. Fast. Really fast. So ist es in Staffel zwei. No, no, no, for real. Don't show me the Netflix show. I hate it. It's too short. For real now. I wanna know how it's done. Joking aside, let's get real now, Google. Also ich finde, wir haben es eher entkriminalisiert langsam. Wir haben es entzaubert. Ja. Wenn man sich denkt, das sind alles Idioten. Es ist wirklich sehr einfach. Ich kann man auch mal sagen, aus Recherchezwecken hat ein Freund Dinge im Darknet bestellt, um herauszufinden, wie das ist, ob das einfach ist. Es hieß der Freund Beffan. Ja, Beffan, und es ist super einfach. Es ist wirklich, es ist Amazon einfach. Nach drei Tagen hat man es im Briefkasten und also, wer das bestellt, und es ist wirklich super einfach. Weil auch, ich meine, die Kommentare, und es gibt halt, es gibt Bewertungssysteme mit Fünf-Se mit fünf sterne prinzip und dann bestellt man bei jemandem der 5000 fünf sterne bewertungen hat und so das einfach ein guter typ aber kann man nicht sagen oh das habe ich gar nicht bestellt klar hat er einfach in meinem kasten ja genau das hat jemand aus spaß für mich bestellt den brief den namen für die woche für eine eine Woche ändern oder so, einfach einen Namen auf dem Briefkasten kleben, kurz. Kann ja kurz einen Untermieter haben oder so. Und dann existiert diese Person gar nicht, an die der Brief geschickt wurde, etc. etc. Da gibt es halt sehr viele Sachen. Man sagt nicht etc. etc., man sagt etc. pp. Dafür wurde extra nach langem Überlegen pp eingeführt. pp und dann ppp. ppp. Das ist also sehr einfach und nur zu empfehlen. Nee, es ist auf jeden Fall zu empfehlen, sich mal schlau zu machen und auch mal den Torbrowser runterzuladen und mal verstehen, was dahinter steht. Kann man auch ganz normale Sachen im Darknet bestellen, so Lakritzer oder so Lakritz-Stangen? Ja, auch, ja klar. Und dann einfach nur damit mal. Warte mal, wo ich Mentos Energy seit langer Zeit mal wieder gefragt habe. Nein! Ich sage, ich schaue mal vom Darknet vorbei. Aber kann man Tiere bestellen? Mentos.onion. Weil du hast jetzt, sag ich mal, es gibt dieses fantastische Interview mit Friedemann, unser Podcast-Kollege Friedemann auch bei Spotify, hat dich interviewt und da hast du erzählt, dass der Freund von dir auch Sachen im Darknet gefunden hat, aber jetzt nicht das, was man normalerweise im Darknet erwartet, wie Auftragsmörder und Kinderpornografie. Aber was denn dann? Also seltene Tiere kaufen oder Waffen kaufen oder was? Ja, vor allem Identitäten ist ein Thing, also Angelschein, Reisepass, Bahncard, glaube ich auch, viele freie Mitgliedschaften für Pornoseiten, generell so iTunes-Gutscheine, Netflix-Sachen, so was. Dienstleistungen eher weniger, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich weiß nur, dass ich jetzt gerne, ich hätte ja wirklich gerne einen Motorbootführerschein und den kannst du entweder in zwei Wochen in so einem Crashkurs machen oder du besorgst den einfach im Darknet. Motorbootführerschein. Ja, aber du musst doch auch wissen, wie das funktioniert, oder? Eben nicht. Bei einem Motorboot halt eben nicht. Lenkst du einfach. Ja, es gibt einen Lenker und Gas. Ja, aber du musst doch wissen, wenn da jetzt so ein Schiff blinkt. Grün, grün, blau, grün. Und du so... Dann fährst du halt rechts ran kurz. Dann fährst du halt kurz auf diesem Ozean. Ja, aber vielleicht heißt grün, grün, blau,, Grün, heißt dann Oh, Achtung, Hai-Alarm. Und du so fährst weiter. Ja. Das war jetzt unverantwortlich. Und dann rammt ein Hai in mich rein und man sagt kurz Oh. Aber wäre das nicht eine Serie? So ein Auftragsmörder-Startup? So Jugendliche, die so ein Auftragsmörder-Startup machen und dann auch so durch verschlüsseltes Internet, Darknet und so, die das aber halt so total nüchtern auch machen und dann planen, wir brauchen die Waffen und die das halt auch irgendwie so durch total Geniale, die dann irgendwie ganz viele Detektivromane lesen und dann da total kreative Mordmöglichkeiten haben und das halt total nüchtern machen, dadurch ganz viel Geld verdienen. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Kurz mal, damals, als ich dir zum ersten Mal, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich noch erinnerst, als ich dir zum ersten Mal von der Geschichte, der Idee erzählt habe Damals habe ich dir erzählt, dass ich eine Serienidee habe. Ja. Weißt du noch? Und Winston Delco hat gesagt, über so einen Jungen, der mit seinem besten Body anfängt, einen Drogenhandel aufzumachen. Und du hast gesagt, ja, klingt ganz cool, aber will doch niemand sehen. Zwei Jungs, die die ganze Zeit am Computer sitzen. Und das war deine Reaktion. Das war aber nicht so ernst gemeint. Deine Reaktion war, na ja, ich hab's ernst im Kopf, deine Reaktion war, dass doch niemand will, doch zwei Jungs sehen, die die ganze Zeit am Computer sitzen. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich oft bei Ideen eher versuche zu überlegen, warum funktioniert es nicht, als zu denken, warum funktioniert es. Ich verstehe, ist ja auch die clevere Herangehensweise. Eigentlich nicht. Falsifikation. Ich weiss halt nicht, es hemmt halt den kreativen Prozess. Das stimmt, ja. Und deswegen glaube ich, funktioniert Wissenschaft und Kreativität auch anders. Ich glaube, du kannst nicht mit wissenschaftlichen Prinzipien an einen Autorenraum gehen zum Beispiel oder an einen Sketch, funktionierenden Sketchwriters. Sondern jetzt erst mal für die Bestie, die der Welt halten. Ich glaube schon. Dann mal ein Jahr lang dran arbeiten. Rumspielen. Und dann gucken, was ist daraus geworden und dann, ja, das ergibt alles hin und vor und kein Ziel. Warum können
die jetzt fliegen? Da sind drei
Zeitsprünge drin. Ja, da war ich Quatsch.
Nur die Moskitos in der
Welt können sprechen, alle anderen Tiere nicht. Was ist da
passiert? Und mein Lieblingswitz, es gibt
den Saturn nicht
in der Welt. Ja,
weil wir einen Gag machen wollten
und dann mussten wir leider den,
egal. Ich will auch gerne für die Trivia, es gibt bei IMDb ja so eine Trivia-Seite und da würde ich gern einfach Dinge reinschreiben. So wie in der Haut des Hellers anderen Fast-Welt gibt es den Saturn nicht. Und der Mond ist grösser als er eigentlich. Moritz' Mutter wurde in Palermo geboren.
Okay.
Fun Fact für die nächste Party.
Nee, die ist in Palermo nur groß geworden.
Genau, ja. Fun Fact für das Trivial Pursuit.
Für das Autosal
und ein Fast Trivial Pursuit, was nur ich,
was ich selber erstelle, will zu wissen,
was niemand haben kann.
Ja, hat Monopoly euch eigentlich angefragt? Nee. Für ein How to Sell Drugs und ein Fast Monopoly? Kein Interesse, ich hab wissen, was niemand haben kann. Hat Monopoly euch eigentlich angefragt?
Nee. Für ein How to Sell Drugs und ein Fast Monopoly?
Kein Interesse. Ich habe die angefragt, mehrmals.
Cluedo-Version.
Oh, Cluedo.
Gibt es das noch, das Monopoly zu jedem Scheiß-Franchise?
Es war Moritz mit dem Drucker,
mit dem
HTML-Code.
Modul im Serverraum. Es war Axel aus der IT im Serverraum. Ich finde ich immer noch einer der wirklich der besten Gags in sämtlichen Staffeln Simpsons ist, wo sie sagen, wir wollen ein Brettspiel spielen, welches Monopoly? Ja, aber welches Monopoly, dann haben sie so Jurassic Parkopoly, Star Warsopoly und Edna Krabappoli. Und das ist der beste Gag, den es gibt, Edna Krabappoli, dass selbst Edna Krabappel, die Grundschullehrerin, ein eigenes Monopoly hat. Wenn ich eine Band gründen würde, ich würde sie Edna Krabappoli nennen. Edna Krabapoli. Crabapoli. Das ist so gut einfach. Edna Crabapoli. So ein guter Gag einfach. Das finde ich sehr gut. Das ist richtig lustig. Die Simpsons sind schon lustig. Die Simpsons machen schon viel gutes Zeug. Momentan, wirklich, schaut es euch an, Tschernobyl, beste Netflix-Serie, die ich je gesehen habe. Ist HBO. Ich würde sagen, beste Serie, die ich seit, sag mal so, beste Serie, die ich in den letzten zwei Wochen gesehen habe. Mit einem anderen. Du nehmt dir, reiss dich mit, wahnsinnig gute, unglaublich dichtgeschrieben, gute Atmosphäre. Nee, super. Also, lasst alle anderen Serien still liegen, das ist die, brecht die Serie ab, beste Serie, Tennebill. Nächste Woche haben wir einen Spezialgast, tollen Spezialzialgast. Wir verraten noch, warum verraten? Sind wir so ein Medium?
Ja, vielleicht klappt es da nicht, dann sind alle enttäuscht.
Dann verraten es jemand.
Aber ich sag mal, der Bereich kreatives Schreiben ist schon nicht schlecht.
Als Richtung.
Wow.
Ja.
Bleiben drei Menschen über.
Warum?
Könnte jetzt auch Jamie Oliver sein, der hat da bestimmt auch ein Buch geschrieben.
Wie macht man
Chicken Nuggets?
Wie macht man? Ist das nicht ein Kochbuch?
Noch bessere Chicken Nuggets.
Doppelt so viele Chicken Nuggets.
Berge von
Chicken Nuggets. Ich finde es aber echt nicht so trivial,
ähm,
ich finde es nicht so trivial,
diese Funktion bei chefkoch.de
oben
die Portionen anzuteilen,
Vielen Dank. ähm, ich finde es nicht so trivial, diese Funktion bei chefkoch.de oben die Portionen anzuteilen, einzugeben, dann auf Enter zu drücken und das einfach nur umzurechnen mit durch zwei mal zwei ist nicht so clever. Warum? Weil ich glaube nicht, dass Gerichte so funktionieren. Ach so, dass alles direkt im gleichen Verhältnis. Im gleichen Verhältnis zueinander steht. Ich glaube, du brauchst immer eine gewisse Grundmenge an Butter. Wenn du jetzt für 0,1 Person kochst, mit einem Zehntel Ei, brauchst du gar nicht anfangen. Wie willst du das machen? Wie weit kann man das runterskalieren? Kann man auch auf so Viertelpersonen? Für eine halbe Portion. So wie so eine ganz winziger Kuchen. Ein halbes Ei, gut.
Ein zwanzigstel Ei, vier Körner Zucker und dann so ein winziger Kuchen. Ganz kleiner Kuchen. Ich will so reiskorngrosse Kuchen, aber davon ganz viele. Aber verstehst du, was ich meine? In diesem Bild, wenn man es mal überspitzt formuliert, ist der Kuchen ja am Ende, der hat ja nicht die gleiche Form, der ist ja nicht innen drin, sieht ja genauso aus. Wenn du so ein mal ein Zentimeter Kuchen backst, ist er innen drin nicht so wie der andere Kuchen, den du gebacken hast. Wie, du meinst vom Verhältnis, oder was? Nee, von der Konsistenz. Schokokern. Der hat sicher keinen Schokokern, ist einfach ein Stück Schoko. Ist ein Bite, ist ein Schokobyte. Generell, ich weiß gar nicht, warum man das nicht macht. Die beste Erfindung ist ja Colorado Mini, Haribo Colorado, seit der Colorado Form, nur halt nochmal in klein. Ich weiß nicht, warum diesen Weg nicht viel mehr Leute gehen. Einfach das, was es schon gibt, nochmal klein und dann einfach. Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist schon eine Road, die schon ganz schön doll entlang gelaufen wurde.
Ja, was ist mit Reiskorn grossen Kuchen?
Stell dir mal vor, du hast so eine Schüssel Kuchenreiskörner.
Gut, das ist ein Cornflakes.
Gut.
Ja, ne? Also ich glaube, das gibt es schon alles in klein.
Auch diese Snickers-Bites, Mini-Bites. Die sind mir viel zu gross. Ich will die wirklich ganz klein haben. Ganz klein? Ja! Und dann willst du zu viel davon. Aber hast du die so weggelöffelt. Ja, ich glaube, ich will alles einfach löffeln können. Wie so ein Reis. Alles in Reisgrösse. Ja. Das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Oder so ein Schokokuss. Bei Reis fühlt man sich so mächtig.
So ein Löffel Reis und man denkt, ich bin der König der Menschheit.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Du denkst dir einfach so, davon könnten Mäuse ein Jahr lang leben.
Und das ist auf meinem einen Löffel Essig.
Geil.
Davon könnten Mäuse und ein Chinesen ein Jahr lang leben.
Ja, und ich zack, zack.
Oh, ist mir was runtergefallen.
Ups, zack.
Sorry, nicht schlimm. Mir egal. Mir egal, ich habe noch Millionen in meiner Schüssel. Ich habe zu viele, es sind viel zu viele. Jetzt habe ich Lust auf Reis. Ich auch habe Lust auf Reis. Vor allem Reiskocher ist, glaube ich, der einzige Fehlkauf, der mir noch bevorsteht. Ich glaube, ich habe eine wirklich interessante wissenschaftliche These für euch da draußen, die zu untersuchen gilt.
Nicht These, es ist eher ein Untersuchungs- und einfach ein Experiment.
Ohne Scheiß will ich wirklich, wenn da Mathematiker unter euch sind, die noch eine Masterarbeit suchen,
ich glaube wirklich, das ist noch nicht untersucht und cool.
Also, es gibt dieses, das habe ich auch mal erzählt, das hatten wir nämlich neulich zusammen,
es gibt dieses Gedankenexperiment, dass wenn Menschen sich ein Glas voller Bohnen angucken,
sie ja unmöglich wissen können, wie viele Bohnen
in diesem großen Glas sind.
Wenn man jetzt aber sehr viel, und dann sagt ein Mensch mal
wegen 80, dann fragt man den anderen, der sagt 100.
Und jetzt fragst du tausend Menschen
und am Ende nimmst du halt
die Mitte daraus,
den Durchschnitt. Und lustigerweise
haben Leute herausgefunden, ist der Durchschnitt
fast exakt genau die Anzahl an Bohnen, die in diesem Glas sind. Weil Menschen sind dumm, für sich genommen, zusammengenommen, clever, mit noch mehr extrem akkurat. So, und dann, wenn man sich so eine Badewanne von Reiskörner vorstellt, fehlt den Menschen ja, wie uns aufgefallen ist, können Menschen unmöglich ein Verhältnis zu dieser Zahl haben. Ob das eine Million oder hunderttausend sind, ist glaube ich unmöglich für den Menschen zu entscheiden. Jetzt ist die Frage, wenn man es da trotzdem tausend Leute fragt, was da für eine Anzahl drin ist, kommt man dem trotzdem näher der Originalzahl? Ich würde halt gerne den Graph wissen, ab welcher Anzahl wird es ungenau wird es ungenau, also wo wird es dann einfach nur absurd und ich glaube diese Zahl ist eine Naturkonstante oh ja, ich glaube das ist sowas wie Lichtgeschwindigkeit oder so, das ist so eine Zahl das ist eine Zahl und ich will vor allem gerne wissen, ist es in der Menschheit hat dieser hat diese Zahl zugenommen.
Mit dem Wissen der Menschheit. Also wirklich besser.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Menschen sind ja heutzutage cleverer als damals.
Ja, vor allem der moderne Mensch hat die mit viel grösseren Zahlen zu tun als im Mittelalter.
Also da war die höchste Zahl vielleicht, wie viele Tage hatten.
Genau, aber heutzutage, wo wir andauernd umrechnen müssen und 0,005 Bitcoin ein Euro sind, würde ich gerne wissen.
Und Milliarden Euro Staatsverschuldung und so. Ja, und man selber mittlerweile durch Netflix eine Milliarde Euro auf dem Konto hat, hat man ja einfach ein Verhältnis zu ganz anderen Zahlen. Klar. Und deswegen würde ich ja gerne wissen, hat diese Zahl zugenommen, hat die abgenommen, wie ist das, und wann beginnt diese Zahl schwammig zu werden? Das finde ich wirklich spannend. Der Versuch ist auch mega spannend. Also, schickt nur diese Zahl ein. Kein, ah, ihr kennt da jemanden, ah, so, sondern schickt diese Zahl ein, wirklich, wenn ihr die Zahl berechnet habt. Dann schickt sie gerne ein, wir schauen uns das an mit unserem Gast nächste Woche. Kein Liebe, Grüße, Hallo, mein Name ist Felix aus, keine Gags, keine mehr, aber auch nicht. Nein nur kein WC-Entequatsch, einfach nur die Zahlen.
Wir wollen die Formel und das Ergebnis
bam, babam, bam. Und eine Adresse, um euch zu erreichen
zu können. Ja, Tabellenkalkulationen,
ganz trockenes Dokument, wirklich, ganz
trocken. Kein Spaß, keine Scherze.
Null Fahr, nur Info.
Das kriegt ihr hin.
Gut, haut rein, macht's gut, wir wünschen euch eine schöne
Woche, nächste Woche wird fantastisch,
wir heben ab, haut rein, bis dann, macht's gut, wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche, nächste Woche wird fantastisch, wir heben ab, haut rein, bis dann, macht's gut, ciao.